i have always really enjoyed doing sets
which i started doing in high school
doing plays from theater and that drew
me along i loved the collec the
collaboration and the camaraderie and i
always really enjoyed the
aspect of the script and the story and
working with the actors and watching it
come to life and working with the
physical aspects was probably the most
exciting to me
i started out as a stage manager and
then became a props person so i combined
those two skills and into set decorating
once i jumped into filmed work
first it was a television show and then
i moved out to la in the early years of
my career after college and uh then
ended up
one step in front of the other
and out in hollywood so it just kind of
evolved it was obvious that set
decoration was the term for it here
back in the in the day in theater it was
prop master so it just worked really
well for me as i really enjoyed telling
the story through objects
well the first thing that comes to mind
is that people think it's all shopping
that all you do is go around and find
things and it's just much more involved
than that you're in many ways i feel
like i'm the sociologist the picture i
have to really look into
the backgrounds of the
characters and the environments
sometimes the
environment doesn't even have a
character say it's a big warehouse that
a big action sequence needs to occur in
and then you have to kind of make up an
uh a character that isn't even around
and then the visual side of it as well
you have to make the whole thing come to
life and make it sing
visually and it's a it's a really
complex job that people don't quite
understand
the studio system where we were able to
i used to be able to go to a prop house
in a single city and rely on that for
most of what we would find
is really breaking up uh the stereo
system of course broke up a long time
ago in terms of the big contracts that
they used to have and that you were
enthralled to one
one of the studios like mgm or something
like that for your entire career
that's been gone for a long time but
still we were based in new york or los
angeles mostly with a few period period
pictures or interesting regional
pictures being done maybe new orleans or
somewhere that
that had an interesting look because it
fit the script nowadays with the
economics involved we're we're finding
our movies that are going everywhere
they could be going to europe they could
be going to the far east they could be
going all around regionally so you're no
longer reliant on a center for either
your crew or your stock of things and of
course the computer is a big change that
we all know about so that internet
research is very important now
and as well of course the computer tools
that we all used in order to design our
sets and along with the visual effects
department coming in and
making the collaborations with them are
completely new and different as well
you